wie es
vorn
der coach muss sie diese in die zentren
dieser besatzung sind nackt geflogen
auf den weg von monza
dass der mond den us tankstellen sind
für zukünftige und fertig suchen
[Musik]
ein grund zum mond ran wieso sollte man
also
probieren
[Musik]
in den 60er jahren spielte sich ein
rennen im weltraum ab die sowjetunion
war der usa dabei stets voraus erster
satellit im all
erstes tier mit hündin laika und erster
mensch mit juri gagarin
aufgeschreckt durch die russischen
erfolge ergriff us präsident john f
kennedy 1961 die flucht nach vorne
der startschuss für das rennen zum mond
[Musik]
eine mutige deadline denn bisher hatten
die usa ein paar affen ins all geschickt
und einen menschen allerdings nur gerade
für 15 minuten und 22 sekunden nur neun
jahre zeit die amerikanische
mond-mission glich einem höllenritt mit
viel risiko und enormen kosten bis zu
400.000 leute arbeiteten für das apollo
programm das nach heutigen maßstäben
über 100 milliarden dollar verschlang
das größte risiko trugen die astronauten
ein paar von ihnen starben während den
vorbereitungen
fast alle waren sie militärpiloten meist
wilde typen die fliegen konnten und
gefahren nicht scheuten zwölf
astronauten landete schließlich auf dem
mond zehn von ihnen hat lukas willecke
persönlich getroffen
der westschweizer hat jüngst ein buch
über die moonwalker veröffentlichen
lukas wti war ein kleiner junge als er
den ersten astronauten life star james
irwin der achte mensch auf dem mond
er war lustig einfach nicht so groß aber
nicht so muskulös erwarte sogar und es
hat mir so inspiriert und ich habe mir
gesagt ja er sieht fast gleich wie jeder
von uns vielleicht kann ich auch an
meine eigene träume glauben
gilead i wurde zwar nicht astronaut aber
immerhin linien pilot er nutzte seine
beruflichen usa reisen um die walker zu
treffen
ein paar von ihnen wurden seine freunde
wie lehrt die kennt die menschliche
seite der astronauten
sie waren keine kinder von traurigkeit
denn um sich auf einer riesigen rakete
zum mond schießen zu lassen
dafür brauchte es keine promis sondern
space cowboys
sie hat dann ihre schöne wagen immer die
corvette zum teil ja wenn sich nicht die
mühe der verkehrsregeln gehalten aber
nicht riesig über algen auf der straße
sie waren auch sehr willen die wie
gesagt sie haben zum teil auch verehrer
und dazu mal das hat das hat überhaupt
nicht gepasst
die kommunikationsabteilung von nasa
probiert diese menschen als superhelden
zu verkaufen einfach perfekter
familienväter und gute amerikaner kann
sich vorstellen kann
in realität sie waren einfach menschen
mit schwächen und stärken und das war
problematisch da zumal für kommunikation
der abteilung gute pr war wichtig
schließlich wurden hier unmengen von
steuergeldern sprich wirklich verbrannt
die space cowboys im zaum zu halten war
schwierig besonders gut in szene
einmal stürzte er mit dem helikopter ab
weil der bikini girls am strand
beeindrucken wollte und da gibt es noch
eine weitere anekdote mit lernen
einen tag vor seinem flug zum mond er
wurde in der nacht auf gehalten von
polizeilich zu schnell gefahren und wenn
polizei mehrmals gefragt aber wer sind
sie was machen sie da hat immer
geweigert und sagen wäre recht man hatte
angst vor konsequenzen
plötzlich kam ein von ingenieur von der
nasa vorbei an dem kolleg aus
deutschland der richtung polizisten
gegangen gesagt bitte bitte lassen sie
diese man freiwald morgen herr fliegt
zum mond um die polizisten haben gelacht
und leicht genervt haben gesagt okay geh
weg zu deinen mund
mit jeder ihrer apollo-missionen tastete
sich die nasa näher an ihr großes ziel
heran dass mond fieber steckte nach und
nach die ganze welt an
auch die schweiz ein paar solothurner
teenager gründeten die nasa das team
apollos witzel und amerika sie planten
ihre ganz eigene mission
50 jahre später sind die männer der casa
immer noch freunde im solothurnischen
gretzenbach treffen sie sich bei
kommandant clemens schenk die mitglieder
der nasa sind so was wie die schweizer
apollo-astronauten verbrachten doch drei
von ihnen zwei wochen in einer
raumkapsel
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das abenteuer der nasa begann im herbst
1968 fasziniert von den berichten über
das apollo-programm fassten sie den
entschluss selber einer kapsel zu bauen
[Musik]
sie dass sich das projekt das das länder
los jedes wochenende zimmerten die jungs
an ihrer kapsel oft bis tief in die
nacht hinein
sie wollten möglichst nahe am original
der nasa bleiben
wenn wir das machen bis zu acht wie
möglich machen
sl also sehr netter karton richte sich
oder bösartig sondern selbst mit hand
und fuß
sie verbauten über 100 schalter und
jeder dieser schalter hatte eine
funktion sagenhafte 3,5 kilometer kabel
verlegt
die teenager
neben der kapsel bauten sie auch ein
passendes kontrollzentrum für den boden
die ground control
während die solothurner an ihrer kapsel
bastelten galt es im sommer 69 ernst für
die nasa
neil armstrong und buzz aldrin waren
dazu bestimmt die ersten menschen auf
dem mond zu werden es war die mission
apollo 11
[Musik]
der dreitägige flug verlief problemlos
doch beim anflug auf dem mond mit der
landefähre eagle tauchten technische
probleme auf armstrong musste ein
zusätzliches manöver fliegen auf der
suche nach einem geeigneten landeplatz
das verbrauchte mehr treibstoff in
houston in mission control man hatte
angst weil es hatte zu wenig einfach
kerosin an bord
doch der treibstoff brächte am schluss
sind sie gelandet sind es war nicht mal
20 sekunden einfach treibstoff an bord
das war sehr sehr knapp aber sie haben
es geschafft
21 juli 1969 kurz vor vier uhr morgens
schweizer zeit der großen moment die
ersten menschen auf dem mond
die freude war riesig nicht nur bei den
amerikanern sondern auch in gretzenbach
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
900.000 schweizer verfolgten die
mondlandung live am fernseher
die presse war sich einig armstrong und
aldrin hatten das abenteuer des
jahrhunderts vollbracht
die mondlandung war ein globales
ereignis das die welt für einen kurzen
moment einte und die usa in die
leaderrolle katapultierte was
fortschritt und entdeckungs geist
angehen
die mission apollo 11 dauerte acht tage
bis die kapsel im pazifik landete die
nasa kapsel in gretzenbach dagegen
wartete noch auf ihren einsatz
der bau hatte viel länger gedauert als
je gedacht zwei jahre
was sollte man nun tun mit diesem
kleinen meister
der hauptsitz von wo sie langsam fertig
wurde nicht ist zielt sie ein vierter
tag die dinge zu verbringen
china labor watch ich drei nacheinander
die vortags links oldenburger in ihrer
rechtsform
unter anteilnahme des ganzen dorfes
stiegen im juli 1970 drei mitglieder des
teams apollo switzerland america in die
kapsel
[Musik]
di luca wurde für zwei wochen plombiert
der rest der crew übernahm die
bodenkontrolle
welche im nachbarhaus installiert war
der dorf elektriker stellte sogar eine
überwachungskamera zur verfügung
die hauptaufgabe stets logisch dass es
gut funktioniert dass die dgb
elektrischer behandlungs geweckt oder
weg entsorgt ist das ist einmal
hauptaufgaben sie und rumänen der
geschichte wo 4 stand 4 stand ist mein
kommando
nach vier stunden aus beachtet man ist
man geschockt fünf passiert ist bevor
sie werden die polizisten abgezogen
suche gemacht und doktorats ermittelt
worden
sind gelaufen
am morgen zum eu staaten und das hat man
immer gemeinsam
das wäre eigentlich nicht nötig das
haben wir einfach zu gemacht dass der
board der blutdruck puls
körpertemperatur alles wurde gemessen
und genau protokolliert das essen war
eine mischung aus importiertem
astronauten food und gut schweizerischen
produkten die irgendwann ja auch wieder
ausgeschieden werden mussten
also mir händ ssj camping club storico
der heimat plastik sagt überstülpt und
denn ich mir auf das schicksal hat es
geschafft verrichtet und nachher hat mir
sofort der plastiksack dreht und zur
bundes uns dennoch alles sollte so echt
wie möglich sein
auch die kommunikation mit der ground
control
der band geschrieben druck sie meinen
die harmoniert und eine schrumpfende
morgen verschwindet ein symbol gestattet
und das haben wir also
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
mit der gelungenen mondlandung hatte die
usa das nun race gewonnen
fünf weitere male landeten die
amerikaner auf dem mond
es gab keine todesopfer obwohl die nasa
im vorfeld damit rechnete abgesehen von
einem abgebrochenen flug waren die
apollo-missionen ein voller erfolg
ganz ohne stolpern ging es dann aber
doch nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für die letzten drei missionen schickte
die nasa einen rover hoch zum mond
die bilden jüngst der nasa erlaubten
sich trotz der lebensbedrohlichen umwelt
des mondes ab und an ein kleines
späßchen somit den allgegenwärtigen
checklisten die die astronauten am
handgelenk trugen bei der zweiten
mondlandung entdeckten die mutter
plötzlich eingeklebte playmates in ihren
checklisten einstreicht ersatzcrew
[Musik]
beim rückflug derselben besatzung war
nackte haut erneut ein thema hören der
mission apollo 12 wenn die 2
man spaziert zurückkamen in
kommandokapsel sie waren kann schmutzig
und dann haben sie sich entschieden
auszuziehen komplett verstauen alle
diese schmutzige kleider und das ist
erstaunlich aber wahr wenn man bedenkt
dass dieser besatzung sie nackt geflogen
auf den weg von monza erde
rund um die treiser mission stieg das
öffentliche interesse mehr und mehr in
ein chronisches gartenhäuschen
weltraumkapsel nachgebildet haben sich
drei junge burschen in gretzenbach seit
einer woche eingeschlossen
aus begeisterung für die mondfahrt
wollen sie die sensationen der
astronauten nochmals eine woche nach
empfinden was hat ein gleichaltriger
davon wenigstens sehen sie zwei wochen
waren einfach denn der hocke oder kindes
machen werdet sich dann ins klasse war
beste rezept schon eine bessere sachen
wiederholt also zuschauer wird die linke
im bund noch spüre dass nicht alle
tassen 50 urkunde hand was mir machen
sondern da halt so kredit gar und frauen
waren dem versuch was der republik wo
bin ich
und das mit dem umgang mit einer sieht
für die elite hauptsache sie sind die
sind ja besonders sie und wendet der
commander an dem band co
ihre mission wurde zwar von manchen
belächelt doch die nasa-astronauten
hielten durch
und sie blieben länger in einer kapsel
als je irgendein amerikanische astronaut
[Musik]
als die zwei wochen vorüber waren
warteten 2000 leute auf den ausstieg der
raumfahrer
[Musik]
viel presse war da die blasmusik spielte
und ihren damen nahmen die teenager in
empfang
[Applaus]
ich sehe fortschritte 30 das ist eine
große freude macht
das ist ein thema so roth
und sie sagen zwei jahre nach der tat am
mission endete auch das mond abenteuer
der nasa 1972 verließ der letzte mensch
den mond eugene söhnen
wir erinnern uns der mann der einst in
einer verkehrskontrolle hängen blieb
[Musik]
vier wilde jahre waren vorbei und
plötzlich interessierte sich kaum mehr
jemand für den mond jahrzehntelang je
ruhiger es um den mond wurde umso lauter
wurden stimmen die behaupteten die
mondlandung habe gar nicht stattgefunden
wien trafen solche theorien am stärksten
es waren die musiker selbst
obwohl astronaut leider nie mehr noch
wenn immer und wieder sie treffen leute
und die zweifel an ihrer geschichte
das schmerz schmerz er und der salbe
nicht persönlich dabei bin mit
dieser strom und der solche leute treffe
dann probiere ich sofort an zu warten
oder dieser astronaut zu schützen
lukas wti war jedoch nicht dabei als
2002 einer dieser
verschwörungstheoretiker auf buzz aldrin
traf und ihn als lügner und deep
bezeichnete es gibt ein journalist ist
giftig und ging beim fast allem und
spaziere und er wollte vor laufender
kamera zu zwingen auf der rechten auf
dem bibel mit dem spruch ich war
wirklich auf dem mond und mit der man
auf dem liebe und bei merkels leute das
war nicht in erfahrung und buzz aldrin
hat sogar ein fast verpasst
aldrin hatte auch mit 72 jahren noch
ordentlich punch und der punch ist auch
wieder in der mondfahrt zurück nationen
aber auch private firmen starten zum
murrays 2.0
das sind zb die chinesen
sie landeten anfang 2009 10 auf der
rückseite des mondes als erste nation
der welt
china plant auch bemannte missionen
ein tycoon out auf dem mond das schreckt
die amerikaner auf vize präsident mike
pence fürchtet um die vorherrschaft im
weltraum
schon 2024 wollen die usa also wieder
auf den mond ein sehr sportlicher
zeitplan denn die nasa hat weder einen
mund länder noch eine funktionierende
rakete sondern nur hübsche animationen
ihr space launch system ist um jahre
verzögert
die nächsten auf dem mond werden
voraussichtlich die inder sein
läuft alles nach plan landen sie im
september 2009 10 mit einer sonde auf
dem mond
damit wären sie die vierte nation auf
dem erdtrabanten
[Applaus]
guten
und da sind auch noch die russen die
haben funktionierende raketen und den
plan dass sie mittelfristig jedes jahr
kosmonauten auf den mond bringen wollen
[Musik]
etwas ist beim neuen mond rennen
fundamental anders als früher
neben nationen spielen auch private
firmen mit
sie sind es die am meisten schub bringen
allen voran
elon musk der rockstar unter den
raketenbauern er und seine firma spacex
lieben den großen auftritt
zu pr-zwecken schießen sie auch mal
einen tesla ins all
[Musik]
chef dieses der reichste mann der welt
ist auch mit von der partie beim mond
rennen mit seinem raketen unternehmen
blue origin fokussiert der bislang vor
allem auf den transport von gütern ins
all
in europa schließlich ist die
französische arien der große player mit
ihrer neuen rakete ariane 6 will sie
bald richtung mond abheben
mit an bord ein mond lander der
deutschen firma petit scientists
scientists ist ein junges aber
ambitioniertes news pace unternehmen mit
70 mitarbeitern und sitz in berlin
mit zum mond fliegen soll auch dieser
knuffigen rover der schweizer pius
bucher ist dafür verantwortlich dass der
rover auf dem mond weder überhitzt noch
gefriert
[Applaus]
scientists planen für 2021 einen
globalen event unter dem label mission
sie machen sich dabei auf die suche nach
einem überbleibsel des alten mond
rennens führte zu dem abholer seventeen
landing seid also apollo 17
damit kann auf sechsmal auf dem bogen
sie sind wir werden italien landet ihr
werdet zwei audimax besetzer der obama
entwickelt hat war audio es im micro hat
mit den zwei euro zurückfahren zu der
länder vor der amerikaner und über die
panisch dass zwei rover unterwegs sind
hat seinen grund so kann der eine rover
den anderen filmen was interessantere
bilder gibt denn die welt soll teilhaben
an der mission und miterleben was von
der letzten aller mondexpeditionen noch
zu sehen ist
was mit der spende wert sind
verschiedene experimente dominikaner
zurücklagen hand wer wird unter die
bereiche vom lande modul verdammen
können wir mit panik see oder das was
davon übrig ist dass sie wahrscheinlich
erstrahlen
das roxy also das auto der amerikaner
damals gefahren sind ist dass das rosa
winkel ist es dass das auto stark
mittlerweile oder statt
das rauchverbot es sind lauter fragen
nicht der besuch einer alten apollo
landesstelle ist clever
so lockt man auch die mondlandung
skeptiker und verschwörungstheoretiker
an
das ziel der mission ist es auch dass
man kann live via video auf dem mond
fahrt und eigentlichen anbieter sind
apollo einer polo mannschaft für die
jetzige generation
das live signal von messen to the moon
wird weltweit vertrieben von red bull
media house
apa
[Musik]
und die wissen spätestens seit dem
stratos sprung aus 40.000 metern wie
weltweites content marketing erfolgreich
umgesetzt wird
[Applaus]
sie wissen wie man groß ist auch
investiert ja was ich ja froh ist
spannend also wie man das nach erreichen
und sich als zuvor gewählt als anregung
auch die macht macht media house also
ich bin da sehr gespannt ob es ist eine
grosse w.zetti sciences sie eingeht sie
könnten als looser dastehen wenn die
mission aber gelingt dann haben sie den
perfekten globalen werbespot zum mond
fliegen und landen auf den grund was man
muss man auch damit machen wir ja nicht
ganz alles rund um ist eigentlich das
wonach die technologie womit der für
entwickler zum das rennen machen dass
wir nachher eigentlich braucht um wie
die mission square leisten und wie drei
und vier wochen bietet besteht sind wir
wenn du nur noch einmal das machen und
jeder hat eine tolle mama sondern dass
wir dafür baut und entwickelt wieder
verwandelt für zukünftige mondmissionen
und dann runter zur verfügung stellen
business leute und politiker alle wollen
sie wieder auf den mond
aber wofür eigentlich warum ist der mond
plötzlich wieder so interessant oder
wettbewerb statt usa und russland und
mittlerer dass man wieder auf grund
eines langfristiges ziel wollte man als
zwischenstation besucher als pro graz
und beatrice als die maschinenbau
ingenieurin an china befasst sich damit
wie der mensch auf dem mond leben könnte
als mitarbeiterin des space centers
betreut sie ein internationales
studenten projekt das sich mit diesem
thema befasst und sie baut mit anderen
studenten raketen für einen wettkampf in
den usa letztes jahr mit einem unguten
ende für die rakete tel
[Musik]
ich leide noch 1,4 sekunden explodiert
das wiener mumok sie und und sind voller
motivation kann aber so schnell ist die
ganze mission eigentlich der fehler für
den absturz lag nicht bei den studenten
der eingekaufte treibsatz war defekt
[Musik]
raketen starten zu lassen war schon
immer eine risikoreiche sache daran hat
sich auch 50 jahre nach apollo 11
grundsätzlich nichts geändert
[Applaus]
auch in maske musste mit seinen space ex
raketen zahlreiche rückschläge in kauf
nehmen
auf youtube zelebriert er seine crashes
und abstürze richtiggehend
ein solches video der nasa undenkbar
[Musik]
schließlich schaffte es bei sechs
raketen zu bauen die wieder landen
können
dank dieser wiederverwertbaren raketen
sanken die preise ein lounge bei spacex
kostet im schnitt aber immer noch rund
50 millionen dollar rechnet mit rund 100
millionen euro für ihre mond-mission
geld verdienen wollen sie indem sie
pakete auf den mond bringen sogenannte
panels können ist ein experiment sie 5
technologie tests sieht war das grund
sprechen ein fünftel findet dass kunst
schlechtes gewohnt bringe das rein
theoretisch auch videos mit flüge
mit bis zu 300 kilogramm pilot könnte
sich das ganze durchaus rechnen
das konzept von petit scientists geht
noch weiter die länder selber bleiben
auf dem mond und bauen ein
kommunikationsnetz auf das von den
kunden genutzt werden kann
[Musik]
der lieferant zum mond sondern eine band
wo die gerade hilft des parcours ja
wirklich kraft betriebe zusammen oder
was wir machen oder die ganze lösung er
sich bedanken
doch da gibt es noch jemanden der gerne
pakete zum und liefern möchte amazon
chef jeff bezos hat jüngst auch eine
mondlandung vorgestellt
bis in den kreis der länder view nun ist
so groß dass er auch für den transport
von menschen genutzt werden könnte base
hofft auf einen auftrag der nasa
aber dann wäre man ja erst wieder so
weit wie vor 50 jahren schon mal doch
eigentlich ist das ziel auf dem mond zu
bleiben und das wird nicht einfach
märz erscheint und man muss irgendwie
niemand trotz der harschen bedingungen
die klappe harmonischen überhaupt nicht
so wie taten es überhaupt nicht
freundlich gegenüber atmosphäre spricht
lange ständig mit auf der oberfläche und
schlimmste sind die strahlen und packt
aus und dankte er steht für das was sich
haben wird und das ganze grundstück zum
lehren was die bedingungen genau sind
und als zweiter schritt einen beruhigen
schutz von menschen bauen wo es wird
eine gefährliche strahlung oder mit
geschützen und dann anschließend direkt
in die geschützt und gab es in hand
kommt an einem solchen roboter tüfteln
eth studenten bald testen sie im rahmen
des internationalen projektes die
maschine im gletschereis über zimmert
dort werden auch weitere konzepte
vorgestellt wie sich studenten ein leben
auf dem mond vorstellen könnten
häuser in lava kanälen sind geschützt
vor strahlung meteoriten und
temperaturschwankungen einpflanzen
roboter recycelt die fäkalien der
astronauten und züchtet automatisch
pflanzen als nahrung
auch der physischen und psychischen
gesundheit der mond bewohner soll sorge
getragen werden trainiert und entspannt
wird in lunaren fitnessstudios über ein
spezielles interface agieren die
menschen mit pflanzen und bauen so
beziehungen mit ihnen auf so sollen die
pflanzen zu einem haustier ersatz werden
und ich glaube ihm dass man eine
interplanetare spezies könnte würde mit
dem aspekt apple unter jobs sondern man
mit aus dem baumarkt auf dem mond kommt
unerwartet neue technologien startet
eine neue zukunft um ganze gar nicht
wirklich vorstellen
die europäische weltraumorganisation esa
denkt schon über ein nun village nach
als testlabor wie der mensch abseits der
erde überleben könnte entscheidend dafür
ist dass man auf dem mond wasser
sauerstoff und treibstoff gewinnen kann
wir rufen morgen im parlament die basis
haben wir das mal ihren zwischenstopp
eine tankstelle im weltall hatte zum
mythos wald als co
der vorteil nämlich eigentlich dass man
morgen in sachsen oder gravitationskraft
theater hat spricht man braucht viel
weniger treibstoff und als auf der hut
und dann soll es richtung mars team
so stellt sich das auch elon musk und
seine firma spacex vor
hunderttausende sollen dereinst auf dem
mars
[Musik]
eine nicht weniger abgespeist de vision
hat jeff bezos er schlägt vor kilometer
lange röhren im weltraum zu bauen durch
rotation wird künstliche schwerkraft
erzeugt die temperatur ist immer perfekt
es regnet nie und die welten erschafft
man sich nach seinen vorstellungen
allerdings bevor man die luzerner
kapellbrücke im weltall nachbaut gäbe es
vielleicht auch eine naheliegende lösung
die wichtigste lektion von raum zeit
dazu sagen wäre sie in acht milliarden
astronauten auf der größten verfechter
raumschiff mit dem namen erde und jetzt
in diesem moment der wind uns reden wir
fliegen durchs weltall mit du mit
tausende kilometer pro stunde und das
ist doch erstaunlich und deshalb sollten
wir bewusstsein unserer kondition und
lernen mehr fröhlich auf diesem planeten
miteinanders leben und auf verachten auf
unser raumschiff
[Musik]